it was 2005 and she was deeply in love
with the cellphone
not just any phone this is the first
phone to put email in her pockets I was
hooked on the physical keyboards the
track pads how fast I could respond to
messages I clung to my blackberry for as
long as I could but then something else
swept her off her feet and it wasn't
it's not you it's me situation this was
a hundred percent BlackBerry's fault it
let itself go and couldn't offer me half
of what an Android phone or iPhone could
but if this were a real romantic comedy
this new blackberry passport would be
the struggling company's grand and crazy
romantic gesture to win us devoted fans
back with a giant square touchscreen and
a touch sensitive keyboard this
blackberry doesn't look like previous
blackberries but it still has the same
purpose at heart though I warn you this
love story doesn't have a happy ending
it looks like a keyboard with a stream I
don't even know what it is
yep this thing does look crazy and it's
pretty much the only thing people notice
about it true to its namesake the phone
is the same shape as a US passport but
the craziest part about the design is
it's American cheese sized 4.5 inch
square touchscreen the width and the
1440 by 1440 resolution displays more
text and Excel cells than the others
okay that might be helpful to some but
what would be even better is being able
to actually hold this thing part of that
awkwardness has to do with the three row
keyboard the narrow panel makes the
phone top-heavy when you type on it and
it means there isn't enough room for a
shift key or even numbers those
important keys pop up is software on the
screen which is really hard to get used
to well I used to be able to type nearly
60 words per minute on my Bold I can
only type 45 on here that's set the fact
that the keyboard doubles as a trackpad
really speeds things up you can scroll
through emails and pick predicted words
with just a swipe I can just swipe to
the left from any screen to get to the
Universal Inbox with all my emails
other messages and I still find it to be
the best mobile email client but it's
with all the other stuff that Blackberry
still feels years behind the Maps app is
slow and lacks points of interest plus
now even with two app stores blackberry
and Amazon's the apps I use every day
like uber and jawbone are still missing
and there's no Instagram
despite the perfect square shape of the
screen not that the passport takes very
good photos anyway for that stuff
blackberries actually okay with an open
relationship no seriously the company
admits that it knows that BlackBerry
users also carry an iPhone or an Android
phone but even if I did still carry two
phones I wouldn't pick the passport the
big awkward design and keyboard makes it
hard to justify room for it in a pocket
or bag even if it is a long-lasting
great email machine and so the love
story ended again I moved on and so has
the rest of the world we communicate in
so many other ways beyond email so I'll
say it again it's you it's not me